Thanks, Lauren. We see that aggression is a part of our lives. However, on the
bright side, we also see that as humans we engage in pro-social behavior. We
would like to start this part of the lesson by going back to the first lesson
on what is psychology? Do you remember when we talked about Kitty Genovese?
Recall that Kitty Genovese was walking home to her apartment after work late
one night. And a man attacked her outside of her apartment building, she
screamed and people turned their lights on. Then the attacker ran away, however
nobody called the police. Next, the attacker returned and people heard more
screams, and still nobody called the police. And then in the end, he ended up
killing Kitty. How is it that such a long drawn out murder can happen, and so
many people can hear the attack, and yet no one, well one person out of 38,
even so much as calls the police? To answer this question, two researchers
Darley and Latane designed an experiment to study what they came to call the
Bystander Effect. Let's take a closer look at how this study was designed. The
researchers had participants who were talking to each other via headsets, it
turns out that the recordings were actually pre-recorded and the participant
was interacting with those pre-recorded conversations. In addition, the group
sizes varied, some thought that they were alone with one other person, others
thought they were in larger groups. Next, some time during the conversation the
participant heard someone choking. Now, remember this was pre-recorded but the
participant did not know that. Now before we move forward with the results.
What would you do in that type of situation? You don't have to type an answer,
but think about it for a moment.